de vrais autobus volant avec des
flotteurs ses avions font la navette
cette fois par jour entre vancouver et
victoria
un trajet de 40 milles c'est le moyen le
plus efficace de relier la métropole à
la capitale de la colombie britannique à
bord 19 passagers cet appareil c'est un
twin otter que la compagnie d'hervé lan
de toronto a commencé à produire en 1965
c'est une légende cet avion à décollage
et atterrissage courts et la viande de
brousse par excellence il peut atterrir
n'importe où sur l'existence incroyable
gros coup sur la crête du montagne en
papouasie nouvelle guinée sur terre ou
sur à glace
en juillet 2016 en plein 10 à un tout et
non ceux de la compagnie kenn borek de
calgary a réussi à évacuer deux employés
d'une base scientifique au pôle sud
températures moins 68 degrés au sol
tout un exploit même pour un avion conçu
spécifiquement pour des missions dans le
grand nord canadien
les pilotes adorent cet appareil
1965 à 1980 8 844 note l'ond été vendus
à travers le monde plus de 600 vols
encore de nos jours ils sont
pratiquement indestructible depuis 1983
c'est cette compagnie vaquer de victoria
en colombie-britannique qui s'occupe de
la maintenance et de la fabrication des
pièces des appareils de dh de l'indh le
pdg de valve gabe et curtis n'arrête pas
de se faire poser la même question par
les opérateurs ses clients plusieurs
nous ont demandé pourquoi cet avion
n'était pas remis en service
son choix est le suivant concevoir de a
à z un remplaçant au 3e ou simplement
reconstruire le même modèle
alors pourquoi dépenser 100 à 200
millions pour concevoir un nouvel avion
qui a exactement le même design bien
trop cher pour une petite compagnie et
les résultats ne seraient pas meilleurs
donc fighting construit le même avion
mais avec des méthodes de production
moderne optimiser les pièces sont
fabriquées à victoria c'est ici que ça
commence gros du cockpit est assemblé
ici les elle aussi
et l'assemblage final du th 6 400 se
fait à calgary il y à 300 employés à
victoria et une centaine à calgary
ce sont les emplois hautement
spécialisés qui tu es bien en moyenne 35
dollars de l'heure il sort en avions
fini tous les 15-18 joue en ce moment il
faut être un expert de twin otter pour
voir les différences mais à l'intérieur
c'est un avion différents
l'intérieur du cockpit n'a rien à voir
avec les anciens modèles
les moteurs de pratt & whitney reste les
fameux pt 6 mai dernier cri même chose
pour tout le système électrique
les lumières des ailes au total 150 ont
été vendus un peu partout dans le monde
russie chine argentine le pérou en
acheter 12 pour des usages en terrain
difficile
paradoxe au canada va qui n'y a du mal à
en vendre trois seulement les avions
construits il ya longtemps par des
remèdes sont encore en usage aujourd'hui
en fait ce sont tous nos principaux
concurrents en amérique du nord
heureusement breaking possède donc tous
les certificats de type de dérives et
l'inde
c'est à dire les droits et les plans
[Musique]
l'an dernier la compagnie a acheté de
bombardier les certificats de tous les
canadairs dont le cl 415 une autre
légende canadienne
[Musique]
canadairs a construit des bombardiers
d'eau de 1967 2015
c'est la référence en matière de lutte
contre les feux de forêt
2 cl 215 est devenu le ciel 415 à la fin
des années 80 avec de nouveaux moteurs
turbo propulseur en france on les
appelle des canadairs et ils sont
vénérés partout à travers le monde
fassi kafyeke est un des principaux
ingénieurs de bombardier
il a commencé sa carrière à canadair il
croit que malgré son âge c'est l'avion
le plus efficace dans sa spécialité
je pense qu'en termes de productivité
bombardiers d'eau canadair est encore le
meilleur on se travaille
devant les hangars de calgary six
vénérables cl-215 ils datent des années
cet avion est construit comme un pont il
peut fonctionner dans les environnements
les plus rudes à ras du sol à des
températures élevées de la turbulence
des secousses il n'y a pas de limite
pour sa carlingue
ces avions 20 km va les remettre à neuf
années chez au départ nous ferons la
restauration de ces avions pour qu'il
soit comme neuf
j'espère pouvoir transformer les
premiers fin 2019 ou début 2000 20 ils
auront des moteurs turbo une nouvelle
avionique un plus grand réservoir d'eau
ils deviendront les nouveaux standards
pour l'industrie jusqu'à ce que nous
produisions de nouveaux appareils dans
le futur avec les certificats de type
vient l'obligation de maintenir la
flotte des quelque 170 bombardiers d'eau
canadair à travers le monde
ces faits dit le pdg je crois que nous
avons très bien réussi je ne vois pas de
grands titres dans les journaux qui
disent que ces avions ne peuvent pas
voler au delà on fabriquait des nouveaux
il n'y a qu'un pas après un été qui n'a
pas manqué de feux de forêts dans le
monde
les circonstances s'y prêtent le marché
paraît très prometteur
la flotte est vieillissante d'autres
marchés s'ouvrent à cause des
changements climatiques
nous prévoyons un bel avenir pour cet
avion décisions dans les mois qui
viennent
après le twin otter le ciel 415 c'est
une deuxième légende de l'aéronautique
canadienne qui renaîtrait un calgary
avec quelques 900 emplois nouveaux
à la clé c'est bon de voir au canada que
il ya des petites entreprises qui monte
en puissance aussi
qui ce qu'ils deviennent des avionneurs
également nous
pour faire des petits
[Musique]